ah summer the flowers of blooming the
bees are buzzing
but the lawns looking a little thick so
let's give it a trim we could use this
the Challenger cylinder lawn mower hand
push power with a respectable 30
centimeter blade with
oh this the boss wrote at 3:20 an
electric mower within impressive 32
centimeter with or maybe this a racing
Lamar with a 389 cc single-cylinder for
Honda engine and well yeah it's quick
that's 13 horsepower quick I mean it
doesn't even cut the grass and you can
race them here welcome to the greatest
show on turf
[Music]
you're more racing isn't for the faint
of heart meet the team that's going for
gold this is Dan Jones
he's the fast one I'd like to think I'm
a good racer I'm a fair race are clean
racer then des Colin click he's the
viable one I'm probably known not for my
outright speed when it gets really bumpy
and really gnarly that's that's when I
come into my own
and the final driver is Dean fuller
he's the distant one I like to think I
was somewhere between the two of them so
work consistently quick I like thinking
and of course don't forget Jason the
mechanic
there's no rivals at all for mayors of
petrol but on the track they're all
rivals together they make the who's
racing team
it's the lawn mowers that we race don't
cut grass originally they would have had
to have cut grass but we modify them to
race them we take the cutting blades off
help for safety reasons obviously these
Mazda mowers are quick 50 miles an hour
plus quick
laughs they often say motorsport is
dangerous there's nothing here to keep
you strapped in so if you come off and
you're going fast it is gonna hurt over
the years the I've seen broken arms
collarbones shoulder blades ribs legs
and cool you might be wondering why
would anyone brace on a lawnmower
well let's do a real quick history
lesson lawnmower racing started back in
1973 but an Irishman called Jim Gavin
and a few of his mates like any good
idea it started in a pub here at the
cricketers arms in Lewisburg Green
England Jim was involved in rallying at
the time and was getting sick and tired
of sponsors sinking their teeth into
this sport he wanted to create a form of
motorsport that was cheap and accessible
to everyone a few beers later the lads
realized hey we've all got llamas no one
would ever want to sponsor something
like that why don't we race those and so
they did and at the first event people
actually showed up to race forty-six
years later the British lawnmower racing
Association is stronger than ever the
lads will be entering into one of the
hardest most grueling endurance races on
the planet the 12 hour lawnmower race so
12 hour race is really the the pinnacle
event of the year expect to have around
50 teams turn up as free drivers per
team they race from 8 p.m. to 8 a.m.
that's 12 brew two hours of racing going
50 miles an hour through the dirt mud in
the dark all along our lawnmower there's
lots of difficulties the main obvious
one is being at night the track getting
bumpy the tracks constantly changing
throughout the night as well to win this
12-hour race for me is the ultimate it's
just the pinnacle of racing you know if
I was to win this race I'd probably
cross the line in tears I've always
thought to myself maybe I'd retire after
that to finish on a high this is the one
I want to win
[Music]
just like NASCAR Formula One there's a
qualifying session
[Music]
[Music]
we just had qualifying working out there
leaderboards quite a good session
actually we've done really well coming
to the last corner before the pitch
straight and got flagged down to you
told them I was on fire
[Music]
so as we can see it seems the trousers
burnt all the seat base or the
electrical wiring looms will be burnt
out back in the pits get it prepared
we've got a few hours now for the race
so till we get it back out in the middle
of everything is this the green beast I
don't know we're gonna be racing rivets
at the front end steering modified it's
still got an original lawnmower engine
the only thing you can take out of it is
the governor which controls how high the
engine revs that's all you can do to the
engine we strip everything away so we
just left with the chassis and then you
build the front axle to something that's
stronger that can take the punishments
and then the gearbox has been replaced
so it doesn't blow up midway through the
race we have to use normal tires I think
the whole idea is that it doesn't matter
if you've got millions of pounds it's
not going to make any difference yeah
it's all about how you build them are
and how you're racing $48.00 gets
through qualifying now it's time to line
up on the grid each ready to mow down
the opposition sorry I just can't resist
the pun for me personally the start of
the race I just get butterflies nervous
you stood on that start line your hearts
in your mouth you're just your knees are
shaking always got rely on their the
machine's gonna start when you press the
button as well and you know nine times
out of ten it won
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you've got your racing head on you
focused on your corners on who your
overtaking and the adrenaline kicks in
with about 45 minutes think roughly then
we'll come in change drivers change fuel
second driver on and away we go
[Music]
Kitely that's my first in so it's not
too bad at the moment it's a bit
slippery in places still but it's not
that bump here
you're starting see the quickest lap was
a rice come in the tracks are getting
pretty well bedded in after electrical
issue the mile was forced into the pits
the who's racing team slips back into
27th place comes flying down the pitch
straight all seemed okay out at the
first corner all of a sudden we lose all
the lights on the front can't see a
thing so I've had to do a whole lap in
the dark come back in when I've been
trying to rush put new lights on to get
back out there it's all kicking off our
track you know there's another mode of
catching fire payoff said a minute but
we've got lights back on and we're back
at error try to push on
when the sunlight starts to come back up
and you can see the state of the track
that's when it hurts and that's when you
start to feel really tired the final few
hours of the race saw them chasing down
the team ahead of them the grass bandits
but at 8 a.m. the race comes to a
dramatic close
the lads finish in 14th I'm done I gave
everything I went on asleep now a beer
and a sweep the best Western team bring
home the trophy after coming back from
43rd place just shows that anything is
possible in normal racing I can't
express what it means I cannot put into
words
it's just mean so much so that the best
bit is 8 o'clock in the morning
everything stops everybody shakes hands
has a hug and then everybody switches
the engine off the generators off and it
just goes deadly quiet that's the best
period so who's racing team same time
next year
[Music]